[Music]
hey Malcolm whatever reviewing today
Malcolm what are we reviewing
don't that blue-ray look dusty
[Music]
[Applause]
how's that well you still got to do the
review the hell did we do all of this I
don't know just like shooting you
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Yogi
Bear a hanna-barbera cartoon making his
first appearance in 1959 on Huckleberry
Hound and his own show in 1961 with his
sidekick boo boo stealing pic-a-nic
baskets upsetting the Ranger of
Jellystone bring that shit to the big
screen the audience demands yes I know
you've all been waiting for this the
Yogi Bear movie is here to fulfill your
yogi fix
I remember the riots and outbursts at
the mere mention of canceling its 90
spin-off show but yo yogi oh I'm not
making that up that show exists it
clearly the potential being utilized
with this timeless icon knows no bounds
thus we have the Yogi Bear movie
premiering in 2010 it starred dan
Aykroyd as the Prometheus dial alien
hybrid of the Garfield movie and Justin
Timberlake as his psychic boo-boo
at last the role these two were born to
play the film was sadly a huge hit at
the box office which means I have to
look over this nostalgia cache in to
find out why is it simply because people
recognize the character and associate
him with good times or could it be
something more no that's it that's the
reason let's get through this bear turd
with Yogi Bear the movie look the Warner
Brothers sign is made of wood because it
takes place in the woods I immediately
associate this with Yogi Bear now
brilliant.i in Jellystone Park for years
families have headed out from the busy
city eager to enjoy a little camping now
come what are you doing calling my agent
they're stealing my Morgan Freeman voice
hello Perry somebody stole my Morgan
Freeman voice what do you mean that
voice belongs to Morgan Freeman what do
you mean we've had this talk a million
times what do you mean to stop calling
you you're my agent
what do you mean quick beep I'm becoming
more and more concerned about having you
around here and much like any Jellystone
Park they advertised the hell out of the
fact that Yogi Bear is there though
another jellystone's he's not as
friendly I
it's time I introduced myself shut up
pic-a-nic basket yeah so in a bizarre
twist dan acrid is actually not that
great a yogi berra impersonator now with
my accumulated talents it'll be a
warning Janet evening from now on the
picnic baskets are going to fall into
our arms I will use tragedy boo boo
watch this or it's that but weirdly
enough Justin Timberlake's voice is kind
of spot-on oh you're gonna get past the
Ranger yogi bored but the 100th
anniversary extravaganzas going on who
knew he was the Daniel day-lewis of Boo
Boo's as you'd imagine yogi spends most
of his days trying to get picnic baskets
coming up with crazy contraptions to do
so I'm smarter than the average bear
you know instead of going through all
that you are bear you could just kill
them hey you broke the matrix and just
like Keanu Reeves I don't look like I'm
really here meanwhile we cut to Ranger
Smith played by Tom cavana
he's trying to keep things orderly with
his second-in-command Ranger Jones
played by TJ Miller I mean were Park
Rangers sir to protect and preserve Oh
at this rate I'll never be Jason Lee
it's got to be better than a crates and
presentation of Rover Dangerfield or
whatever the hell he's doing when you
have a mind like mine
it's true you could be saying shit like
this we're being visited by 23 different
species and 23 different kinds of ships
you know III I'm not alone on this but
it turns out a filmmaker played by Anna
Faris wants to do a documentary about
yogi let she's already off to a rough
start you cave and hide her boom Mike
very well I was hoping just have to you
about filming a documentary here okay so
are we actually gonna let her be funny
or is she just the woman yeah highlight
all the plants and animals I see okay
you could just replace it with a pair of
boobs and a smile and pretty much get
the same reaction so what are you here
to film an unusual brown bear brown bear
when the talks those are so rare none
that I can think of he's eaten for four
he's speaking of kids ask yourself if a
child would follow this conversation
from the mayor's office well if we don't
have anything to sell maybe we can
profit off what we can't sell if we
rezone Jellystone Park as agricultural
land we can sell the logging rights this
company says they'll give us thousands
of dollars in acreage this is a story
about a talking bear in a tie you can
say a witch is haunting the forest
nobody cares the wager introduces Yogi
and boo boo to the filmmaker I'd like to
introduce you to Rachel Johnson who's
here to make a nature documentary
[Music]
goddamn you sound goddamned I think
someone has to lay off the pazoozas
peddled beer would you guys mind if I
shoot you huh yogi come back and meet
your fate you stop helping please
actually my favorite part about this
movie is qivana as the Ranger because
every moment he's on screen he just so
looks like he doesn't want to be there I
know there's a mic for his audio but can
we get a mic for his inner thoughts just
shoot me just shoot me give me out of
this dump like this Bigfoot Jar Jar
Binks that supposed to be next to me
urinate on her to mark her as your
territory Jesus Christ easy piss on her
he told me said this honor what the hell
kind of movie is this what you think oh
no a black limo that means the 90s
villains are about to deliver the 90s
plot I just hear the area oh yeah you
know I'm the only other Ranger here
right
I so hope they mock you for this is
Deadpool - I am closing your park down
673 you got to be $20,000 in the hole -
right 30,000 560 - okay not exactly sure
how a mayor can shut down a national
park but it gives the Ranger a chance to
raise money to save the orphanage I mean
grandma's house I mean the farm I mean
cinema paradiso I mean die don't give a
shit
a lot can happen in a week hey you know
what I'll even get you started
what's the admission fee for one car
again $30,000 oh shit I guess I walked
into that one
meanwhile boo boo feeds his pet turtle
had almost only animal seems wrong while
yogi makes another device to steal
picnic baskets but is stopped by the
Ranger you I've got to stop stealing
food so that campers will leave here
happy but they do leave here happy
getting your food stolen by Yogi Berra
season a flash with this rotten lu6
putting winning a shit there are
repercussions to stealing people's
picnic baskets not in my experience sir
on the other head well I didn't know
there was a wrong way to use the Wilhelm
scream but Yogi Bear found a way that's
so distracting you can replace it with
this unfunny engine job Smith meanwhile
tries to see what Ferris is up to I
don't know how to talk to girls how do
you think I spent so much time with the
animals all you have to do is scratch
their backside and you've got a friend
for life and you try that with people
and all of a sudden you're the weird
girl on the bus and nobody wants to sit
next to seeing house the only funny line
the movie I guess I'm glad I went to her
he ends up asking her to dinner at his
cabin but yogi seems to be quite the
cook at a blogger where this Park needs
is visitors and lots of them I'm just
hoping this is gone from another
universe so we can just see this happen
forgive me
but to me you can't enter centuries tell
snuggle puss I love it
[Music]
you will stay away from people do you
think you can do that for me fine I'll
just retreat into this forest garnished
by slaughtered Smurfs but oh no the big
hero six donor might be changing sides
why is it only going halfway down again
oh okay alright so we did a double tap
or do I have to present this goes on for
10 seconds hello to all of you
you're welcome why is a guy with your
talent doing this insulting grunt work
you gonna be in charge now while you
still know everything just ask the
combination of Shia LaBeouf and mr. bean
over there you put me in charge in a
second Ranger Jones agrees to sabotage
the 100-year anniversary of the park but
it looks like yogi unintentionally might
be ahead of him I can't take it boo boo
two days without a tasty treat dee I
gotta eat people I'm a bear no
apparently he's referring to the picnic
baskets particularly the one with
doughnuts
[Music]
well grant in 2001 parodies have so
rarely been done but the what does this
have to do with anything he wants
telling us okay why is he suddenly
floating his face towards a giant one I
don't really see any connection or
similarities
hey Critic I could really go for some
ice cream
I I'm more ice cream
you look like you're having a fantasy
about being in Empire Strikes Back
except you're playing both Darth Vader
and Luke Skywalker and you're talking
about ice cream
hey you recognized it that means you
understood it no I described it
understand it I did not I'd like to
think they're the same thing or not I
like to think they are what do you mean
stop calling or you'll call the police
what kind of agent are you
you think we might be nuts
there's no bite about it okay what's
this review doing to everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
so major Jones comes across Yogi and
boo-boo and looks them right in the eye
telling them to do what they want
Manolis he would look them in the eye if
anybody cared about what they were doing
where are you looking he's right there
people see fireworks every day in the
city they came here because they thought
they'd see something different
thanks again for helping me with the
fireworks I don't know where Ranger
Jones disappeared to I mean what'd you
think I was gonna do set off fireworks
at night day fireworks are the best I
have never felt so gushy wrote a song
about you saw you at the station the mic
is on you might use that we all got
bonus on yes the mic yeah thank God I
didn't catch the mic in his head when
this is over I'm gonna jump off a bridge
hey weird everybody's wearing clothes
with no writing on them what's up with
this girl it's just something wrong with
her is she the only actress crying god
I'm gonna drop tonight yogi however
interrupts with a waterskiing show which
of course ends up setting off the
fireworks
[Music]
of course people flee and the Ranger is
stuck not making the amount he needed to
keep the park open I thought I guess it
wasn't enough screwing up my leg no this
time you had to go and bring down this
entire Park look at that face that's the
face of a guy holding a gun under the
camera how smart of you now
[Music]
I could watch this Ranger forever so we
sent to a different Park while Ranger
Jones is put in charge much to the
filmmakers dismay you and I are just two
people who care about things that nobody
else doesn't that's why we're alone or
maybe that's why we found each other
Rachel you and a spark of one thing in
common you're both moldy and green and
all the wrong places you both deserve a
better man than me and I'm gonna see if
legends of tomorrow need the Cameo
Ranger Smith was right my whole life
I've been different but it's done
nothing but hurt people yogi what are
you doing get my gun
boo boo it's time to add myself to
Nicolas Cage's wardrobe he decides to be
an average bear which leads to well
average bad jokes Oh could this get any
worse oh I don't know a piece-of-shit
punchline we've heard to death nah it's
nothing compared to a repeat of that
amazing window gag come on unbelievable
have a good day Ranger Smith I hate this
cart I hate it you know this is trying
to look good do some research and it's
not interesting but it's more
interesting than this boo boo of course
convinces yogi to go back to his normal
ways when they see the park is starting
to be shut down
[Music]
I'm humorously obligated to plate this
after that line what a king yeah you
think
nobody is gonna hurt Jellystone
you know noticing a pattern that bad
Warner Brothers films use the Superman
theme think about it Yogi Bear kangaroo
jack Superman Returns
it's a weird cycle Yogi and boo-boo go
to fine Ranger Smith quiz you can tell
is still acting like the devil melted
his nuts a week ago mr. Ranger I've
learned two things my soul is being
murdered it's being murdered by this art
to harm me from Honeymooners covered in
paddy to specific hair come on
shotgun ah no no I me second we're bad
oh no they blew my people to poop it's
they find that blue booze pet turtle is
actually an endangered species and thus
they can't take down the park but the
mayor now running for governor and his
men trying to stop them
buddy I just gave cunnilingus to a
turtle this is my life they decide to
use Yogi's glider from earlier to fly in
and grab the turtle and has ever been a
good film with a glider not that this
movie is ever gonna redeem itself but it
is kind of a weird kiss of death isn't
it you he jumps off the glider to grab
the turtle and boo boo defies the laws
of gravity to hook the bungee cord onto
him to whatever God you believe in
personally I put faith in the energy of
the collected unconsciousness I'm
actually a Muslim wouldn't you never ask
about me they bring the turtle to the
bad guy and why are you taking the
turtle to the bad guy what you spending
all this time keeping it away from him
you think I care about what the law says
get this thing out of here before
anybody else sees it you know I'm the
mayor of Nowheresville how do I have all
this power they get the turtle but bear
has recorded the mayor's evil plan and
tries to play it in front of the crowd
they just need a distraction check this
out boo boo diggin it
we are fascinated by their thoughts
about what the law says there's about to
be a riot out there I need you out front
what there are bear boats this calls for
a damn awkward walk seriously what was
that was he mimicking the way the
original yogi walked the mayor's
associate tries to get away but ferrets
uses her years of being with animals to
her advantage Snow Leopard yeah you can
drag the scene out all you want I gotta
have a ferris on me I'm not gonna yell
cut they put them there away and of
course more people are drawn to the park
making it a success again and naturally
yogi is still there to encourage
criminal behavior we're gonna eat the
dog to Korean food tonight yeah I guess
that's kind of like a bird oh my god I'd
rather do five scary movie sequels than
one of these well crap if they're Mike
in my head too that gives a shit just go
see overboard and that was the Yogi Bear
movie I think I'd rather watch this I'll
give it credit that it's short it's only
80 minutes long and it strangely feels
about that long it just flies in does
some shit and then flies away like a
bird leaving a dump on your shoulder
it's not good but there's worse things
it seems almost silly to get angry at it
it's Yogi Bear the movie what did we
expect even the cartoon isn't really
anything that's phenomenal
this is inoffensive I guess but it's
also dumb and just forgettable
aside from again the Ranger is dead
inside reactions I swear this movie is
almost worth watching just for him but
aside from that this is a shit in the
best gift you can easily pass on
I mean it's not like this movie's gonna
begin when Dumber after watching it stop
trying to block my calls and do your job
I'm on the Titanic now you're my agent
stop asking me that
Jack I can fly just don't watch it while
operating heavy machinery
I'm not a Schnauzer kind of guy remember
it so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
you
urinate on her to mark her as your
territory
you